on this episode we take a bunch of
questions from Chinese students
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
Carrie B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 259 of
the askgaryvee show live from my hotel
room in Hong Kong the engine invasion is
underway dirac Singapore in October I
might have just committed to going to
Beijing on that same trip January I have
been long waiting I left you guys a
little bit of a clue in can of my great
ambition to enter the chain that the
Asian market excuse me and I'm excited
about it and the trip here has been
remarkable I'm completely infatuated in
love with Hong Kong and I've got seven
to 15 more incredible cities that I will
attack address and visit over the next
four to five six months here I pick up
the camera now and show two of our three
or four homies that helped us say hello
guys these are two two amazing teammates
two amazing teammates on a team that has
helped Syd on our end translate my
content create opportunities and this
episode is extremely special because
they helped curate an opportunity of
what is it five or six five or six
questions from Shanghai Tech University
students which I'm going to answer right
now and and I appreciate that guys and I
want to publicly appreciate you guys for
all the hard work and the hustle and as
you could tell by the meeting we had
earlier there's a lot more to go and so
there should be a pretty awesome journey
yes I agree
do you rock the trip so far great great
right yeah fun trip alright let's get
right into the first question
hello Gary I'm how long I'm so glad that
I can have the chance to talk to you
through the review before I start my
question let me just briefly introduce
myself so that you can have a general
idea on my background I'm a senior to be
undergraduate students from Shanghai
tackle University and is now studying at
Harvard as a visiting undergraduate I'm
majoring biology while I'm also a big
fan entrepreneurship and management
because personally I
consider entrepreneurship and science as
something closely related say for
scientists actually see me to think from
ultra preneur point of view so that your
discoveries can be made into something
useful while for the entrepreneurs
sometimes they do needs advanced
scientific tools to make their normal
ideas into reality the good thing is
that from the past decades we do see a
lot of good examples where people
combine entrepreneurship and science
together typically in the IT field
however the interesting phenomena is
that in the field of biology these
philosophy doesn't work well for some
reason and my question is just what do
you think that might be the main factors
that caused these phenomena in the bio
world and also from your point of view
what do you consider as the biggest also
the most promising opportunities in the
field of biology in the following two or
three decades looking forward to your
reply and many thank you how long thank
you so much for the question this is
going to be a fun episode I have a
feeling everybody can enjoy these video
questions look I think the reason that
you're seeing a lot of people in the
biology sector biotech things of that
nature struggle is that people hold on
to romance people hold on to the
establishment the decision makers in
your field oftentimes don't want to
change an entrepreneurship that energy
is always disruptive and oftentimes
takes people that are on a pedestal off
that pedestal so there's human behaviors
of defense he understands once somebody
is at a pedestal that they feel is the
height of where they are they start
going on defense and not letting anybody
take them off they're not continuing to
aspire so I believe a lot of it is human
inefficiency as far as open
opportunities the truth is I believe
that in the in the biology what you
because of Technology and the Internet
infrastructure and the enormous advances
we have in science is everything is
vulnerable I often say in
entrepreneurship which I understand much
better than biology you know that Amazon
put bookstores on notice early uber put
car service black limo companies cab
services on notice but everybody is
vulnerable I would argue because of the
advance of the advances in technology
literally everything in every sector is
today vulnerable over the next two
decades and so for me I would take your
energy and deploy it against the thing
you're most passionate about because
they didn't evitable will be disrupted
over the next two to three decades this
concern hey Gary this is young phone
sound hi I have a question for $8 it's
very difficult for them to collect a lot
of data in their first three or five
years and they really need these data to
improve their products and the algorithm
big companies like Google they already
have a lot of data and they can develop
similar products using this data easily
so what's your advice for these ai's
dollops thank you chan young my advice
is to not fight Google in a game that
Google is more likely to win the number
one rule I have about startups and
entrepreneurs is when David is fighting
Goliath you never fight Goliath game so
your question if anybody was paying
attention to makes this very easy which
is creating a business that is
vulnerable to the Google infrastructure
or any other company for that matter
whether it's Amazon or or Apple or
Facebook is just not smart and so what
you need to do is you find small niches
that either you hope you can move so
quickly in that by the time they decide
to attack it they're better to acquire
you or that you've amassed so much
market share that you'll be able to
sustain the blow of that competition and
that whatever you're left with once they
enter will still be meaningful very
similar to the case study and I'll give
you a great one the case studies compact
computers versus IBM in the 80s they
found their niches they found their
products that and they were able to go
up against the Big D giant then they
also used software companies like
Microsoft where I
to really democratize and create a huge
company and they pinned up with their
competition so I think if you want to
spend some time on Google or whatever
search engine you'd like to look at the
compact computer story of how they were
able to navigate and grow to such it
that is a perfect story and we see it
every day it's speed only speed Trump's
somebody that's bigger than a giant
right play your game and so fine niches
and go extremely fast otherwise you have
no shot mm-hmm good story yeah you
should really look into it the other
freshman girl she said she's a biology
student as well also very interested in
art and design and entrepreneurship even
I'm I'm sometimes very confused what I
will do and what out the con after I
enter to the society however I really
have a sense and motivation to combine
all all I learned and what I like to one
piece which is something I don't know
and maybe combined by something that is
very irrelevant so sometimes I'm really
lost can you give me some suggestions I
sure can't is what non-expansion money
because I don't know what to do yeah I
mean look the good news is 90% of all
students don't know what to do and
everybody's overthinking it so what I
would tell you my friend is you need to
really look inside your heart and figure
out what she yes you think when you talk
to yourself what does she want to do I I
would tell you that the number one thing
that you should focus on is doing you
know you are not going to figure this
out being in your own head just start
doing do it all do some of it together
mix art and value mix entrepreneurship
and music like just doo-doo-doo-doo
do you understand how young you are do
you understand that you can just do for
the next 10 years do and do and do try
some company for three years try some
internship for two years try some you
know medical you know sabbatical for
four years and you wake up from those
nine years and you're 31 years old your
baby so you're going to have a very
difficult time in getting me upset or be
empathetic to being crippled by having
all these interests put them all
together separate them apart spend the
next decade I mean that tasting and
trying the problem is you come from an
environment where people are going to be
judging you if you're not succeeding in
the short term and that is your
vulnerability the judgment of society
your parents or somebody else too as
you're trying and failing until you find
your things you may be lucky and your
first thing maybe the great thing you
may be lucky and your fourth thing and I
said that on purpose slowly you may be
lucky it's the first thing you may be
lucky it's the fourth thing but you have
to have the internal strength to be able
to hold off society and family judgment
while you navigate if you're so confused
well they need to do something about it
and the answer is to do a bunch of stuff
over the next decade to put yourself in
a position in your early 30s to enjoy
your world and I get that the you know
listen I've been doing a lot of data
collecting here I understand the
pressures especially in China around
becoming successful so you can get your
apartment and start your family I'm
aware everybody's got pressure hi Gary
after I learned something about you I am
pretty interested in on how the idea of
online shopping came up with you and
made you so successful
I don't think only luck is enough for
such things to happen and besides on how
can we predict the future or in other
words how can we know what would world
be like especially what kind of things
may be popular in the future can you
give us a suggestion on how we should
think
thank you very much you're welcome very
much 1996 eBay was around Amazon was
around the world hadn't accepted its
upside I bet on consumer behavior and
innovation and things changing so I can
predict the future where there are five
were there five one two three four five
where there are five liquor stores in
America that had online stores when I
launched No so it feels like I'm
predicting the future but I'm taking
innovation that's happening around me
and I'm deploying it against my own
reality at that time my bet was that we
would pick convenience over history
because that's what humans always do and
that's why it was so obvious it'd be the
same reason that I know that AI is going
to be very important it's the same
reason that I know voice it's very
important all the things my friend about
the future are happening right now the
question is have you calibrated how big
they're going to be in seven to ten
years and are you looking the other way
while it's right in your face I've been
very good at understanding the arbitrage
is of attention and infrastructure that
drive business over the last twenty
years and I plan on doing it for the
next 50 years of my life so for me I'm
giving it to you right now whether it's
using Kol s to drive your business
whether you know you know whatever it
may be right you know there are so many
opportunities out there that are so
black-and-white obvious yet we tend to
look the other way because there's no
historical reference point directly to
that attribution but there is
celebrities have been selling products
for a hundred years there's just new
celebrities got it
so my punchline is very simply the
future is always the present right if
you're guessing the future you're
guessing if you're moving quickly in the
reality it seems like you're predicting
but you're just reacting like that one
right has a good one to go through yes
yeah of course yeah it was at it for
them yeah okay you get that good well
then you get to ask one okay my question
is in China Le Pain WeChat yes payment
yes in the trillions in the US
Beauty maybe from mobile payments
because there's fragmentation so go
ahead what's the what's it going to take
if I want wise in the u.s. yeah I do
the reason the u.s. is lagging behind is
because the giant internet companies in
China are fully integrated if Apple and
Facebook merged tomorrow you'd have it
the end I mean you know it's it's just
the dynamics look look there's one thing
that people give credit to the Chinese
entrepreneurs that isn't taken into
account which is the government
involvement matters like that's not how
the u.s. works you know like you know
Steve Jobs wasn't able to call at the
time George Bush and so you know that
Facebook thing that's emerging yeah just
I need I need that because I'm like so
like you know I love when I listen as
you can see my energy so Pro Asia plenty
Pro China but we can't forget that the
big dogs had competitive government
Vantage's that created a full stack in
the US it's called Apple Amazon and
Facebook in China it's just all
integrated yeah is there one more
oh maybe this one person I'm good guy
we'll just lay okay damn it I think I
think was it bad and I think it is now
we write of the Chinese Jesus Daniel
include
yeah once you ask one I think we're good
they say they wanted to prepare yeah
bang oh you did right right okay good
listen I mean well while we're hanging
out here good time what you're seeing
what you're vibing is just a very
thoughtful exciting moment in my career
to me looking at the Asian market is
almost as wide open as exciting as when
I started vaynermedia or when I started
to get involved my dad's business with
Wine Library or when I discovered the
internet or when social media web 2.0
was emerging from the web 1.0 era
you've got a question okay glad I'm son
such a good rant no I mean I was real
punch I being the this expansion into
the Asian market both in mainland China
and surrounding marketplaces is going to
be a really fun front
good so this question is following Daren
he asked about how does one start a
process of architecting one's business
and when when you are get architecting
your own business how do you gain
support foreign or an unpopular decision
yeah so oh Jesus Christ I know okay how
do you convince your team to work on it
yeah so you can mix your team by one of
two things either motivating them
through enormous optimism or forcing
them to some dark dictatorship the
middle one the first one is how you
begin to architect is backwards you try
to figure out what you're doing
backwards you know you're trying to
figure out why you're doing it and what
the opportunity is and then once you
understand so for me when I started the
intermedia oh my god oh wow there's a
lot of reasons why the biggest companies
in the world
don't market properly they're not smart
enough hmm
not really they don't care it kind of
but wait a minute there's four major
marketing companies that dictate the
entire world and they're pushing the
profitable items for themselves and
there's not a lot of talent that sees
where the world is going what if I built
a machine that was so incredible at
marketing that then when I bought brands
in the future and I ran it through them
I could take the value of a brand like
k-swiss from 100 to 500 million in sales
very quickly because I only did Kate
influencer marketing I only did Facebook
I only did the other above that okay why
don't I do that okay now the way I'm
going to do that is going to build an
agency that only sells the best work it
won't be popular at first but I have to
do it because my long term vision
requires me being the best marketer of
the future and more importantly the best
at that time okay I'm going to hire a
bunch of kids at first because no real
marketer is going to want to work for me
because I'm going to tell them a TV is
[ __ ] and banner ads are [ __ ] and
you know radios [ __ ] so they don't
believe in this is 2009 they don't
believe in Facebook and Twitter but I do
so let me get a bunch of kids and I'll
show them I'll teach them the fresh ID
they don't have preconceived notions and
then I'll pick up market share and then
when the biggest brands in the world
realize they have to use it I'll pick up
early market share and
learn to visited isn't it that's how you
do it you start backwards I started with
my ambition to buy the Jets how am I
going to do that flip businesses how am
I going to how am I going to do that by
building a machine around my marketing
skill and then you know getting people
to buy in is pretty easy and then the
middle one is my favorite you know
making unpopular decisions I only make
unpopular decision d-roc was an
unpopular decision everybody told me
that that was super narcissistic it's
very weird the [ __ ] do you have somebody
following you around for and and I
thought that was probably a great idea
what I mean the second I feel a lot of
pushback and I actually thought of it
and thought it was a good idea then I
know I've got something big so those are
my answers do you have the self-esteem
and the confidence and the ability to do
all those things as a whole different
story
anyway Asia is going to be good great
trip and I really appreciate everybody
watching my question of the day when you
think about the Asian tech ecosystem and
I'll throw the whole kit and caboodle
into it take it any angle that you want
what are the first things that come to
mind you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]